like unwinding everything that's built
up on top of this pure Consciousness and
then from that being able to integrate
into the body into its Partnerships
unions all kinds of things and then just
watching how that is way more creatively
powerful MH
yeah
and and also that like there are certain
things that I feel like have been
conditioned purposely by
um quote the for forgetting like the
kind of that's a toxic gas of forgetting
right right
and uh and one of the most powerful ones
that is showing up more and more as with
Father fatherly discipline of like hey
wake up is that you can't just be
leaking your own Sexual Energy
everywhere right right that's like the
most powerful force in the whole Cosmos
and you're just like fap fap fap fap
over here subscribe to this only fans
thing like whatever like oh we can [__]
on the third date whatever no problem
like has no repercussions even though I
really love you or whatever
like like Madness yeah yeah Madness and
then you wonder why there's no secure
attachment then then you wonder why
nobody can get married and last long in
marriage and have 3 6 12 kids
are all awake
children like like
Jedi it's just you talk about it but you
can't manifest it because there's
certain toxic gases that are still built
up and running show yeah and it's this
um with the Sexual Energy piece it's
like you will wear rose-colored glasses
most often because you're dealing with
the most powerful energy in existence
and if you haven't integrated and and
had a level of mature
to handle that responsibly you're going
to feel oxytocin and call it
love I'm in love Yeah and in that
yearning for love which is and through
the oxytocin from sex it's like it's
such a power powerful biological bonder
you will look over often not always but
most people they'll look over tons of
red flags they'll falter on their own
values probably because they don't even
know them but so much will get put under
the rug just keep giving me this I'll do
whatever it takes for this feeling and
it's called being ruled by your feelings
and when men enter that space which is
like what we've been encouraged to do by
Society it's like be more in your
feelings which they're pointing to
something that's true yeah we need to be
willing to be vulnerable and honest and
if that makes us cry then we have to be
willing to fully go there but if we
start following the well this just feels
good so I'm a yes to it we become
pleasure addicts and we're not actually
Discerning we're not cording we're not
yeah yeah exactly there's no discipline
there's no wait let's have a a space
where we can actually determine if we're
compatible without the rose-colored
glasses on all of these other levels
because at the end of the day the sexual
act is it's 0.1% of the time it really
is and it's it's such an access point to
intimacy yes it creates life and it's
not in of itself it's not doesn't create
intimacy
people can have sex and not be intimate
right so it's like man to remove that
for a period of time where there's so
there's an attraction and you're you're
that's that's why I like what the
Christians point to wait till marriage
for sex it's not that that needs to be
an arbitrary rule it's that they're
pointing to like a sobriety of like am I
in this for the right reason perfect
yeah exactly a sobriety of those tox tox
tox nauseous mhm G gases uh and that
that that sobriety giving you the
ability to look on all of these levels
of compatibility and relatability and
everything everything it's so juicy it's
so juicy and it's not yeah it's not like
you said it's not there filtering
through uh must get sexual intercourse
yeah yeah yeah exactly
yeah